he came to kill the devil yes
I love him so much he's good he's the
best
and
if you think I'm evil yes
wait until you're just wait bye bear we
watch this clip so many times every time
I watch it I see something new that I
love about it this one to me is scarier
than candy conquer no I think he's more
crazy
I mean look at this every choice he
makes is just like master closet I love
it I love her
audiences have seen me a version of this
character in the series Loki they edited
that I think they that Paul Rudd was
like just tell me what to say yeah 100
except for what Kevin fired
very different Kang is an infinite
number of different personas
did we just see the gang Dynasty they
just showed it in a featurette I'd be so
mad I'd be like wait a minute just four
different he remains his N3 King to
conquerors from quantumania well in the
Marvel I don't know if this is still
recording sorry in the the opening for
quantumania it's he who remains that's
in the a right yeah yeah let's see who
remains when the elevator doors open
into his office
and hey y'all and he's got his his uh
not hey y'all but his hey y'all his hey
y'all not to be confused with hey y'all
by Outkast welcome back to New rockstars
phase five opens the door and paves the
way to phase six is the Kang Dynasty
we've seen all the kings we theorize
their motives but when we reach the Kang
Dynasty who will save the Multiverse
today we'll break down all the info we
know behind the Kang Dynasty and the
second half will go over which Avengers
we can expect to see down
let's see down the road no see on the
road to Kang Dynasty the road and you
know who came up with that I think it
was empty that was our man Mt who isn't
feeling too well he could be with us
today I happen to be in town at the new
roster's office so I I Justin I could do
this remote but we miss umt we do as I
said many times we're empty without
empty but on the plus side you get the
name of the entire episode and kind of
pitched the entire episode so and this
is inside Marvel new Rockstar's weekly
Marvel reaction show and I'm Jessica
Clemens and Eric Voss is here and this
seat is open for Mt I know we we pour
one out for it no I'm not gonna pour
water which rug has been through a lot
yeah there's already like a wet spot
it's kind of like you know that weird
hole that opened underneath the
cordyceps guy and uh yeah and just
randomly cartoon hole that's what's
about to open down here a giant fart
will come from the ground
um wait be sure to check out nerd Riot
Dodge shop where you can always grab the
latest and greatest new rockstars gear
right now you can check out our new line
emerge inspired by the Mandalorian
season three
from the Mandalorian season three Eric
is grabbing it right now
look at our bad boy look at this look at
her little man I said thank you this is
QVC now
and then and there's also still time to
grab our gear for Quantum Mania before
the quantum Rome portal is closed
forever support the channel and check
out our great merch options over at
nerdriot.shop I the the look at him go
but also again there is also Deep dive
merch and don't forget to subscribe to
the newest Channel The Deep dive yeah
Eric is dropping his back to the future
deep diving oh my God the Back to the
Future Deep dive is incredible Devin
came up with this beautiful way to
convey what what I'm talking about I
figured out things about the movie that
I never thought about I've seen that
movie 20 times and only now when I like
it had to be my job I was like holy crap
your choices and what movies to go back
and talk about are really specific
because I'm like these have a lot of
holes I know that I've missed not holes
but like ideas that I miss completely
things I overlooked also the science to
all of activity understand so I will be
watching this breakdown for Easter eggs
and understanding and you can let go of
the science I think that's the real
truth of Back to the Future is it's the
one time travel movie that cares the
least about the time travel mechanics
and that's what makes it so great maybe
they just started it okay but anyways
let's get inside this inside Marvel on
the Kang Dynasty and the road to it so
the King Dynasty was announced almost
eight months ago and following the death
of he who remains in Loki season one
Marvel announced that phase five and six
ultimately will revolve around our big
bad Kang and his Sublime variants the
road to the Kang Dynasty is up for some
theorizing but there's so much release
we can work with so let's try to piece
some things together so we're all on the
same page of where the MCU train is
going I'll summarize what we know from
interviews Publications and the Marvel
movies so far and then we can stop and
discuss as native how's that love it
okay so first first going first which we
kind of already all are aware of because
we just saw quantumania so we know that
he's appeared in Loki and quantumania as
he who remains and King the Conqueror
with a post-credit scene teasing what
everyone believes to be the scar
Centurion amortis ramatut and Victor
timely along with an arena full of wild
king so we know that whatever happens
here here probably directly affects
what's going to happen in Kang Dynasty
or at least speed bump to what happens
in King diamonds now do you think we
will see all of these Kings like in some
form or is this just like a tease of
like the variety of characters where I
feel like we it um it's kind of like uh
when in Multiverse Madness he's closing
the portal and we see the uh Spider-Man
villains and it's like okay we saw them
but we're only going to focus on like
six major ones okay so there's more in
that crowd that might be in there that
we're gonna focus on but I don't think
it's gonna be every single one yeah I'm
just curious like if this like they had
their version of Rama Tut of scarlet
Centurion which We've joked is does not
look like Scarlet it doesn't it doesn't
I mean why why would you call that guy
call him anything else but then amortis
who looks very much like a mortise uh
from the comics
um but like you know Peyton Reed has
said like oh well I don't know if we'll
see these guys exactly in these forms in
the future it's like well then why did
you take the time you think we're gonna
get we got a close-up of uh Lizard King
and then we got the the photo of
Blizzard King and we're never gonna see
Lizard King again uh I you know well
there is a reptilian Kang from Mesozoic
24. from Earth Mesozoic 24 and I think
that might be him I think that's the
idea and we do not need to see him again
he's a big weirdo big weirdo I do with
that being said let's go to the next one
because I want to see him again
shangshi's director Destin Daniel
is tapped to direct the Kang Dynasty and
is to be written by Jeff loveness what's
the connection between Shang Chi's
Destin Daniel to the Kang Dynasty
so far so yeah we have the we have Mt
that made a video about the he's made a
couple videos about the color
um comparing how like Chuck Cheese is
orange to Kang's purple but also the 10
Rings being something that Kang created
or stole from one Wu in the past and I
do think those that's still a theory
between the 10 Rings uh and uh Kang the
Conqueror still is sound it still makes
sense I think there is some link between
uh the three things like the ten Rings
the Bengals and Kang yeah I think
there's some kind of link among those
three things and yeah I do think there's
that I also think like the the ten Rings
having the pulsing Beacon you know we've
speculated it could tie to Multiverse
Menace it didn't uh or it could tie to
Galactus or something from the Fantastic
Four I think it's like it's tied to Kang
in some way or the Kang Dynasty that's
like part of their alert Beacon and
there'd be I mean it could also tie into
the cree the marbles well that's what
I'm thinking too I'm like but that's the
plus side to all of this is like uh
throw logic out the window for a minute
and when I say that I mean that every
King can exist in any form so it's like
we had Rama we had a pharaoh what other
historical element is going to be
another king and which kind of also
leads me to this if if he who remains
could weaponize Elias do you think
there's a king variant that could have
weaponized the dweller in darkness oh
absolutely in fact the dweller in
darkness could be like some form of
Elias that escapes exactly or a variant
of Elias oh does the dweller in darkness
does he have variants I mean the dweller
in darkness is supposed to exist like in
between timelines right or in between
universes he's some kind of like
antimatter that exists that that devours
matter and turns into nothingness so I I
think it's hard to say what the dweller
in darkness even is because they didn't
even give him a full name it was like
their name for him all we know is that
he came from like talo and they
mentioned that there was Dimensions
beyond that that he came from but yeah I
think there could be connection I think
that's like where a lot of my questions
always wind up is like what's the
difference between the dimensions and
the Multiverse and their connection
because I'm like there could still be a
king if there is a king that I pitchless
don't know how true this could be if
Kang is actually chiffon and created the
oh my God I agree
the the the dark hole the dark Holden
cursed Wanda I mean uh that's that's so
fascinating it's just like because I'm
just like if there's so many variants
what happens when we come across the
variant that doesn't know science but is
a Mystic Arts or knows chaos magic or
something else that's a good point I
mean Marvel's really gonna have to they
got a lot of work to do to Define what
things Kang is the man behind the
curtain of and what things he had
nothing to do with and the things he had
nothing to do with why why didn't he
touch us what was he afraid of or what
was he not powerful enough to touch 100
I do think with uh the connection for
the Shang Chi director and uh the Kang
Dynasty will definitely still be within
those Rings though I think that is I
think that's the key I think that's a
good key and if it isn't written down
now it will be written down in a movie
coming up in an interview with
comicbook.com loveness uh love this did
a bunch of interviews lately a bunch of
them and he talks about Kang Dynasty the
writer of quantumania's Jeff loveness
said I think for these bloodthirsty fans
there's a little movie called Avengers
Kang Dynasty I think he'll bring the he
He also mentioned in an interview with
variety I think we really have an
opportunity to have a passionate
vulnerable villain on a crusade against
himself and the Avengers are in the way
do you know how
that meaty both those things are yeah
okay so for the first part regarding
he'll bring the heat he's talking about
burning people out of time is it metal
it has to be a metaphor I think so I
think I mean bring the heat there's a
lot of like sports metaphors with that
right but like I think burned them out
of time that's that's the language
they're using around Kang is it's like a
burning sensation that leaves a burn
scar it's it's scalding someone it's
cauterizing a wound right Ashley he's
the one who came who brought the heat
into finding what cauterizing a couple
weeks ago
um but yeah I think he is going I I want
to see the king in action I think to me
the most exciting couple frames in
quantumania is when we flash to Kang in
some alternate timeline that Janet has
seen yes it's some burnt out Forest his
eyes are lit up his scars are lit up and
people are screaming as they're getting
vaporized and I want to see what it
means to Kang physically to burn someone
at a time because it's not a macro
perspective it's a micro perspective he
is in these timelines going person by
person in my opinion vaporizing
load-bearing people that need to be
there for that timeline to make sense so
he's he kills specific people yes to do
it I was gonna say so he literally when
you say burning people at a time it's
like yeah I'm fake like I'm literally
zip and you're gone you're dead you're
dead out of this existence do you think
every King is going to have that ability
every King variant and that's why he
said they're going to bring the heat
it's like every King is going to have
some form of burning people out of time
I think every Kang is deadly I mean look
if you have the ability to manipulate
timelines yeah you can come up with like
a laser that comes up out of your hand
like I don't think that's that hard to
imagine that they can they can vaporize
someone it's not that hard to vaporize
them on a week if we can Master
Multiverse travel you can vaporize
someone I think it's the willingness are
they are they willing to go that far and
it's Kang the Conqueror he has no
barriers he in his mind it the ends
justify the means he's got like a Thanos
Eco uh terrorist mindset of I have to
call the Multiverse down because too
many incursions are killing the
Multiverse so I have to like population
cull and I have to population control
um so in his mind it's it's a will like
he's basically killing uh as many people
as he can to prevent the Multiverse so
anyway there's no there's a lot no I was
like there's a lot that actually goes
into this and it's coming up okay
because he interviews he says a lot of
stuff so after again I want to reiterate
his last uh quote that he said was I
think we really have an opportunity to
have a passionate vulnerable villain on
a crusade against himself and the
Avengers are in the way and then later
in that same interview he mentions
um in in regards to the Avengers movies
this is a day where we need these guys
and this is a threat we cannot handle
alone and this is a seismic shift in the
world this is a generational event and
our old generation is gone or retired or
scattered so it compels a new generation
to stand up so he's already talking
about for Kang Dynasty that we're going
to get a new generation of Avengers who
are those new generation I I think we
can assume it's like the young because
when you say generation it means people
it means like a time of people it's not
because if he was just saying hey it's a
different it's a different time he would
have said it's a different time but he
said generation specifically so are we
is he putting like uh Yelena uh Kate
Bishop is he putting Cassie in Kang
Dynasty to fight the Kings yeah I think
King Dynasty is going to be that
generation two of Avengers that we've
introduced in in phase four and I mean I
think that also includes She-Hulk right
she's a Gen 2 of if you consider Bruce
Banner the first generation so I think
this is going to be the lineup of it uh
but I think you'll still have some gen
one like I think you'll have a Peter
Parker in there I think you'll have a
doctor strange and he still fits into
the word generation because he's still a
baby so that's true he's a kid yeah he's
a Gen 2 to Tony yeah I think the uh when
I'm saying the keyword generation I
think he's like yeah genuinely most of
the new people that we've been
introduced to are very young but there
will be a Captain Marvel there will
still be a Monica Rambo it's just like
the amount of young people to older
people is significantly high can I ask
you to speak as freely as you feel you
can oh are you okay yeah
how excited are you by an Avengers King
Dynasty by that particular lineup of
phase four Avengers not that excited
thank you for being honest
ly very careful which of them they
include and which of them they bench we
get into okay hold on to this hold on to
this you guys okay I'm sorry our second
part is about which Avengers are going
to be a major threat and why they are
going to be the reason for the King
Dynasty okay because I think there are
major ones because like for instance
America Chavez who can just jump
Multiverse is probably a huge Target for
a king I would think things are like we
need to go after this girl that can
literally just rip and bring people into
every Multiverse but I think that is a
young person that I would like to see in
the Kang Dynasty because it's so
compelling makes sense okay Bishop I
love to death but I'm like I need what
is this Arrow gonna do to a King that
can phase you out of time you you shrink
down a Cassie Lang to hang on to the
arrow and she goes up his booty hole and
she's got such good aim it goes right at
the booty she's the coin flip she's so
good at just flipping a coin she's
almost like Gambit or Bullseye right
that's how good she is
stop college student and fencing
extraordinaire Kate Bishop can do it has
perfect aim just naturally gifted
perfect thing hey
um but yes I think uh you make a good
point I I think it's interesting that
they say that the adventures are
scattered okay so it's proves that it's
intentional that you have cap on the
moon you have Doctor Strange in the dark
dimension Hulk keeps going back and
forth It's the car doesn't make any
sense uh uh half of them are dead we
don't know where white vision is yep
maybe also on the moon we don't know if
uh Scarlet Witch Is Alive or Dead you
know probably in some other Universe
hanging out with her kids so I think
that's it tells us that's intentional
that these gen 1 Avengers are scattered
and you need kind of a second generation
to come and redeem them but I think
that'll just be the story of King
Dynasty Secret Wars all of them will
come back but like yeah how do they get
in the way I guess is my question that's
my that's my question too and we'll get
into it because there is extra
characters that are not a part of the
younger younger generation but still
older and still there that we're gonna
get into okay yes let's get into it so
loveness also mentioned being super
excited to write for no more uh so we'll
probably be seeing him in the Kang
Dynasty yeah he's very excited to see
that and he also mentioned uh in a
different Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter simulu also mentioned working
with Dustin Daniel was fantastic
he wants to expand the relationship
can't wait to work with them even more
together in the future he also teased we
might see him in something sooner than
we think and I know Kang Dynasty is kind
of far away there's a lot of properties
in between the two but I think when
you're a director you love working with
your lead Star right so Ryan cougar love
working with Chadwick Boseman so of
course Daniel uh Dustin Daniel cren
would love working with simulu so
simulus shung Chi and no more showing up
in the Kang Dynasty what does that mean
for Kang Dynasty is it going to be a
ring situation or is it going to be a
water situation uh I think we'll see uh
like historical battles right yeah I
think that's Neymar is old right like
he's super old and we didn't really know
what he did in all of his time but he's
been linked with solo Khan forever I
think this is Neymar's opportunity to
like do some historical what-ifs like he
can he can prevent colonialism that like
led to his people and he's going to be
like well wait that leads to my people
being where they are right now so
how do what do I do now like Kang is
going to put him in these kind of
impossible scenarios of like well what
would you have preferred yeah I really
want to see those scenarios play out
because it seems like what we got from
Black Panther rock on forever he
genuinely is like I'm not coming out of
the water unless you guys come into the
water like until you mess with my people
is when I come out I don't care about
anything above the water I don't care
about anything on land so what does one
of the Kang variants do that alters him
unless they shift something in the world
so majorly that the entire water and the
oceans just like wipe on the land it
depends if you're gonna look at it from
The Aquatic perspective absolute if you
look at it from the mutant perspective
it's a different conversation because
Pharaoh Rama Tut we later learned why he
went back to ancient Egypt to become
fair aromatite is he was trying to tie
in with the history of ensavonder the
first mutant on Earth apocalypse so if
Kang is uh retconning the history of the
MCU to uh genetically imprint mutant
kind into existence that could either
erase or alter some way namor's timeline
because Neymar has the X Gene we think
we assume it has a mutant so yeah Namor
could be the representative of mutant
kind in Kang Dynasty and that's why he's
so excited oh my God I love that I'm
here for that or if Kang was like
because in um then he kind of want to
like make apocalypse's air or take over
him what if there is a king that's like
I'm gonna no more I'm gonna take him
under my wing oh okay oh no not like
yeah not like that uh but no he's gonna
be like I want him to be my Heir because
he's so he did the same thing and
mortise basically did the same thing
with Scarlet Witch he was like this
woman is very powerful I need to make
sure she's on my side I think that would
be a lot of situations where King isn't
dumb enough to be like I need I can do
this on my own he's gonna be like no I
should recruit this guy I should recruit
like white Vision I should recruit uh
Adam Warlock he's gonna recruit a bunch
of people oh Lastly lastly for uh
Publications and interviews love this
compared came to conqueror to Magneto uh
stating he loves Magneto he said that uh
Magneto lost a lot and by the end of his
arc when he finally raged we kind of
understood why right we were on magnet
there's a reason we understand
killmonger's anger we understand
Magneto's anger right
um with that being said should we expect
to see Kang lose and lose and lose again
then by King Dynasty we get the ultimate
worst version of Kang and he just
destroys everything could he potentially
be setting up a new battle world oh well
yes I do think they're setting up a new
battle world I don't know if I can
handle seeing Kang lose and lose and
lose and lose again that feels like Team
Rockets lasting off again he who remains
kinda lost and then we already have this
loss so maybe those are then the amounts
of losses we're gonna get just those two
it feels like he remains one at the end
of Loki he got stabbed but like you see
his big statue at the end and I feel
like well maybe he remains didn't win
but the Kang Dynasty won the King
Dynasty day I feel like uh quantumania
was a really awkward loss for Kang the
Conqueror though like maybe I mean even
doesn't it feel like the Kang Dynasty at
the end of the movie is regrouping
they're like we need to stop wasting
time like I was bummed to see Kang the
Conqueror lose I want to see uh Scott
Lang die I want I want to see him I want
to see him win and die but win styling
guy but I do think there's so many King
variants like especially in Loki if we
see like 12 they're not all gonna
succeed so I maybe those count as long
losses like the an episodic episodic
just episodes how we're gonna probably
see a couple of Kings not make it can we
see just one sequence in one of these
movies where it's like Doctor Strange
versus dormammu in the dark dimension
where Doctor Strange dies and in the
same shot another doctor strange
respawns right behind him that's what I
want for cats I want a whack-a-mole king
moment which is like you thought you
killed me I'm right behind you what if
that is what uh uh doctor strange and
Clea start doing they just keep doing
that that's they're wiping them that's
their role playing that's let me get
involved so we'll get back to inside
Marvel but first we'd like to take a
moment to thank all of our sponsors that
help bring inside Marvel to you if you
want to have any chance of defeating
Kang in the upcoming Avengers Kang
Dynasty You're Gonna Want to get a good
night's sleep and here at new rock stars
we love our sleep time with Helix and we
have for many years Helix makes premium
mattresses and bedding that are
customized to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped right to your door
do you know how heavy this box is it's
shipped to your door you just gotta drag
it in which Helix mattress is right for
you don't worry about it Helix made a
sleep quiz that matches your unique body
type and preferences to the perfect
mattress for you based on your different
sleep positions and firmness preferences
they have something for everyone's
unique taste and if you sleep with your
partner you can take the Sleep quiz
together and find something that's
perfect compromised for both of you
which is needed one person sweats too
much one person's too cold figure it out
the best part the best part about all of
this is that Helix delivers your
mattress right to your door I tell you
guys it's very important and with free
shipping in the US plus Helix has a 100
night sleep trial so you get more than
three months to make sure that you love
it or you get a full refund Helix
mattresses have a 10 year warranty
that's a decade and they even offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
too far away I love my Helix and I think
you would too if you're looking for a
new bed check out Helix you can click
the link below or go to helixsleep.com
inside Marvel to get 20 off your Helix
mattress plus two free pillows that's
Helix sleep.com inside Marvel hey we
also want to thank hover for sponsoring
this episode if you've ever thought
about starting your own business or
creating a brand or sharing what you
know with the world the first step is
finding a domain name to get you off off
the ground hover makes creating a domain
name super simple you don't even need to
know what you're doing to get started
because hover provides easy to use tools
a straightforward user experience and if
you ever need help their super friendly
support team is there to guide you give
them a call and a real life person will
assist you hover is a trusted and
popular choice amongst millions of
people launching any kind of brand or
blog or business they even provide
domain names that go beyond the
standard.com you can really make your
Endeavor stand out with extensions like
dot shop dot Tech dot art and more they
have over 400 domain extensions hovers
connect feature makes it so simple to
connect your domain name to lots of
website Builders with just a few clicks
if you're ready to get your ideas online
hover has the domain name to make it
happen head on over to hover.com Marvel
to get 10 off your first purchase that's
h-o-b-e-r.com Marvel for 10 off your
first purchase perfect and for our
second portion of this video which might
go a little bit quicker than the first
what could stop the Kings and Kang
Dynasty I've spoken about this before in
one of my videos generally speaking of
the MCU characters we have so far what
do we think is like a major threat to
King because those characters we should
expect to see in King Dynasty people
like Wong Doctor Strange Clea America
Chavez even Moon Knight as long as it's
Khan shoes there because I think they
can reach like a supernatural level but
also if concert ran into ramadet he
probably knows all of his weaknesses oh
yeah so I think that would be of great
portion of the phase four we have like
the eternals Black Panther Spider-Man
Jack Russell from world oh don't forget
about him don't forget about him I feel
like people forget that's why maybe they
sleep on him they sleep on him and he's
a werewolf can you imagine a werewolf
don't sleep on it first off don't sleep
on a werewolf secondly you saw what
those ants did they gang a werewolf I
know you could tear up three okay don't
forget about Jack Russell from werewolf
By Night She-Hulk Miss Marvel and then I
put etc for the rest and Etc who do you
think will be major threats to King or
appear in King Dynasty and also keep in
mind the movies that are expected in
Phase five and six I didn't include like
the Fantastic Four right yes I think
they're going to be a major threat
because Reed Richards always has that
nuclear option of I will kill myself and
cut off the bloodline to Kang
and I think he'd be willing to do that
he's like I will eradicate myself out of
existence if it means said Kang doesn't
uh be able to so I think that will
always be the that will always be the
nuclear option that's why it has to be
Doctor Doom that's okay that's why he
has to be doctor too because Doctor Doom
wouldn't do that but the read win I
think Reid would uh or he says I will
kill myself and I will kill my two
children and I will kill my wife and
they're like Dad Dad do we get to vote
in this and he's like no no no but no no
I think yes that's an option I think uh
characters with mysterious apocryphal
Origins characters that Kang does not
know how they spawn into existence or
where they came from the higher
evolutionary the high evolutionary Jack
uh not Jack Russell uh uh Jake lockley
uh one of uh Moon Knights one of uh um
uh Stephen Grant's altars that's true
because I don't think Kang is an expert
in mental health I don't think he goes
to therapy he clearly does not he is not
trained in in these in these things in
these phenomena so he's not going to
know where an altar truly comes from
because that's a secret known only to
Stephen Grant and to Mark Spector what
trauma created did Jake lockley I don't
think we will ever find that out until
until somehow you think that's going to
be a huge threat to Canada you think
he'll be prepared for
for not Jake not no it is Jake for Jake
uh lockley who's working with konshu
yeah but he won't be a you won't know
about Steve or the other one right I
think he might know about because he can
always say oh he like anything that we
have seen on screen in the MCU
presumably uh Kang or he remains his
scene like there's a written record of
it somewhere that he can check he'll
just like choke the Kevin robot until he
tells him like what his origin was but I
think when it comes to uh we don't know
what Jake lockley's origin was so
presumably neither does Kang and as long
as there's the one altar of that person
who exists there will always be someone
from Moon Knight to bond with yes and
then if you have a God who can use you
as an avatar that is something that Kang
will always have trouble with I think
that's an issue I can't I genuinely out
of all of the Kings I'm so excited to
see more for ramadai in that situation
especially because you know he has to be
aware that there's Gods using people as
vessels
yeah he wants to be the one to destroy
them probably he's like they're gonna
interfere with what I'm doing right and
the fact that he used Alexander the gray
8 as like an influence for the character
I think he was buds with Alexander the
Great he knows that Alexander the Great
was one of amit's uh avatars
um and he maybe Kang was his right hand
man who was like hey you you don't need
almond um it's crazy and then that's
that was his trick to be like Alexander
the Great and and Alexander the Great
could have been this Immortal figure and
Kang's like okay I need to undo this
conqueror so that I can be the great
conqueror so yeah I think that and then
I think lastly the ultimate this is
gonna sound right I think in a word love
love will be oh she has to be mistress
love and just the concept of Love Kang
cannot feel love and until he I think
the way they'll end up defeating Kang
and getting Dynasty in secret Wars is by
getting him to actually truly selflessly
Love ranslayer by letting her go uh that
will that will be like okay I don't need
to be this madman anymore
I person and die something that's
interesting that uh phase four was like
like if what's death if not love
persevering or whatever and then this is
just what's love
what's love and they mentioned that a
lot on the features I mentioned that in
the interview it's like yeah even
Jonathan major is talking about Kang he
was like this has a lot to do with time
but family and love and connection
because no one thinks about that when it
comes to time they're thinking about how
many different outcomes there are right
right and I was like oh this is an
interesting pool maybe it doesn't matter
but now I'm like oh no it does matter it
does he doesn't know what love is he
that's why I think in genuine generally
like him and the high evolutionary is
going to be best friends because they're
gonna be like we don't have that bone
that sympathy or empathy right we don't
care
um I I'm thinking about characters like
that I think he's gonna try to take Adam
Warlock once a high evolutionary loses
him I think that's a great person to try
to steal and if mantis does have any
abilities that's also a group person to
steal yeah I mean if love is really the
answer to how all of our problems are
solved like characters who are the
greatest empaths are going to be the key
to all of it and I think mantis is right
at the top of that list she's a great
one oh I mean love is so young unless
they age up they can age up immediately
for Kang Dynasty but it's like that
would be the one I'd be most fearful of
I mean and maybe that's the way they're
going they're like hey New Generation
but also remember this character that
technically is the strongest thing I
know do we need it to be uh was it
Christian Bale or Chris Hemsworth's
daughter who played I think no it's
going to be someone else yeah they can
recast we don't need it to be Chris
Hemsworth's daughter to play this role
in fact it doesn't even need to be an
actor I'm okay with this being like what
eternity was just a CGI bring the first
Cassie back I'm sure she's old enough
now to play the I'm telling you we need
all three Cassies we need the first
Cassie little baby girl Cassie we need
Emma Furman Justice for Emma Furman she
did a great job on that doorstep I agree
I can't a hug Paul Rudd and not be weird
um she did a great job okay well this is
it for this episode of inside Marvel a
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
oh yes please
and Mt come back to us we miss you feel
better buddy
you can blame me all on me subscribe to
the Deep dive Channel out Deep dive in
on follow me at Lulu underscore Clemens
follow MTM ascertainment subscribe to
inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast thanks for watching bye empty
come back
foreign